foreign
[Music]
weekly hangout here at 2PM Pacific here
in sunny San Francisco California It's
Five O'Clock Somewhere especially if
you're on the East Coast Pete Brown
what's up hey man how you doing I'm fine
yeah how you doing I'm all right is it
sunny today I feel like that was no it
is it's been a weird two sunny days in
San Francisco for like people who aren't
local or don't know it's kind of a
cloudy City Rob you're local sure am
yeah you've been here how many years
like 36 forever yeah yeah is it 40. what
how old are you oh I turned 29 like a
couple weeks actually yeah oh yeah I
remember that you're an October birthday
it's going well anyway yeah uh we got a
lot of docket we kind of have another
long show I got a lot to fit in a lot of
releases a lot of uh kind of just like
random things we want to talk about in
relation to death stranding and
kojima-ish stuff uh but first we want to
start with Star Wars Battlefront oddly
enough we haven't really done much on it
since like it released last year or
around that time at least and you've
kind of been you and Aaron maybe have
been one of the two of the people in the
office Rob that kind of have been coming
back to it with the DLC yeah each time
around just kind of touching on what's
new what's changed
um this time around it's
I go back and forth with Battlefront
um we've all played it I'm sure like you
know as a Star Wars fan like you have
these awe moments and you appreciate the
visuals and the sound effects and all
that stuff and you know it's all done
really well but then you just start
getting frustrated along the way and
that's where I'm kind of at with this uh
DLC but it's been pretty cool I think
it's a it's a neat little package so far
I'll just give you more of those sort of
like all moments or like the Nostalgia
stuff I mean is that kind of what this
game that sounds like that's pretty much
all it can rely upon I haven't played
any of the DLC but I imagine like
getting more of that is probably yeah
and that's where yeah and that's it's
exactly that and that's where the the
run I go with this stuff it kind of ends
where it's like I feel like I've seen
all the spectacle of it and then it kind
of just dries out because the gameplay
is just not that great I mean you know
I'm sure there's a fan base who
appreciate it and clearly because there
are a lot of people who are pretty good
at that game and
but yeah this time around it's Death
Star so there's like three game modes or
Maps so to speak and they all kind of
um transition into each other the first
being a uh the rebels attack a star
destroyer outside of the Death Star
um and then the next is on the death
star rebels attack they're trying to get
to it like it's like a um
it's the game mode it's basically a like
a moving spawn point where the rebels
are trying to get R2D2 off the Death
Star and onto this Rebel transport
because he has the Death Star plans so
like the movie
and then the next is just the Death Star
Trench Run
um and I feel mixed on each one of those
um they also added new Heroes there's
always two in each one for each side
Imperial Rebel this one is uh bossk the
Bounty Hunter which do you know what
what alien race he is I always forget I
don't know I don't know he's not like
because Greedo is what a Rhodesian
rhythians like that yeah and then the
other one being Chewbacca himself which
I haven't been able to play yet but um
they have some pretty you know they
always have interesting kind of uh perks
and abilities Chewbacca has one I guess
where
he just goes his typical Chewbacca Roar
and then surrounding allies near you get
beefed up stayston is fantastic because
the audio Yeah I'm terrible at those so
I think if you get to try to do it it
looks like boss has some sort of thermal
vision I think right
no
that I'm never gonna top not bad that
was more of a Tuscan Raider but I'll
never talked about that anyway but okay
so these I mean it's the Death Star
Interior right so I would assume unless
there are big hangers you come into it's
kind of claustrophobic confined like
close quarters or that's what I that's
why I don't really like the um that
stage
um
just because it's so hard like you're
just constantly dying or at least I am
and I think everyone is I mean
it's tough yeah it's really close
quarters
um it makes you realize that that death
star with all those steep no railing
like drops how funny they are with you
know jet packs are some of the like it's
like the hot item in that game so people
were jumping up and then hitting the
ceiling and then falling down these
things it's breaking their neck right uh
it's tough in in these corridors but you
know it's again these the spectacle
value is really cool so you'll see like
what I imagined to be a rendition of the
control room where the Death Star uh has
you know all those scenes another one is
I think it starts off with R2D2 near the
uh prison area where Leia is however you
walk down that famous hallway and it
just goes it's it's not connected to
anything it just actually literally just
goes off boundaries so yeah when I first
start off I saw about eight guys running
down there and then all turning back
because there's nothing you know there's
nothing to go towards to that Gap where
uh Luke does the grappling hook across
it and then Leia like hugs him so tight
that she's like inside his chest I
didn't see that no you don't see that
you see some hangers and you see
um definitely the same area where
Obi-Wan turns down the shields oh
spoiler uh I want to ask you guys a
question collectively like so seeing all
this stuff is great and this is like the
first time we've seen sort of like the
classic Star Wars movies represented in
whatever next-gen right like these
consoles they can only whip this stuff
out once in a while before it starts to
feel like yeah we've seen this recently
do you guys think that the the fact that
they've kind of executed on this in such
a middling average way means that
well maybe this is the best we're gonna
get this generation and that kind of
sucks because hell imagine like a really
good Recreation of this stuff this gen
they're not going to try to do it again
immediately following this
does it feel like a missed opportunity
because I kind of feel that way with
Star Wars specifically yeah yeah well
you know yeah like attacking the classic
movies like showing these scenes that we
all know and love and doing in a way
that is just not quite delivering that
like wow you know like it's all caveat
by the things that make this game kind
of uh sure I mean like I reviewed this
Beth uh last year and that was my thing
it was like the spectacle is there for
sure and it's there especially if you're
a Star Wars fan you're kind of screaming
over Hoth in a snow speeder but there
wasn't much substance to the combat
um in order like in terms of like making
use of the Star Wars license and whatnot
I don't think we've seen anything
spectacular recently at all
um I know like the Old Republic people
gush about but I mean that's like you
know that's not like the classic Star
Wars movies um I don't know like the
Studio's working on stuff right now
there's you have people at EA that are
working on it like Amy Hennig Studios
working on that one kind of wondering
what that's going to be like but
Battlefront has always been middling to
me at best
um I haven't been playing the DLC I
think that was the overarching question
I want to ask you is any of it worth
coming back for is or is it is it like
lending more Vitality to the game yeah
like so that interior uh Death Star
stuff with the actual um infantry combat
again yeah it's just it's just a cluster
[__] like I don't even know where I'm
going for the most part like yeah I see
a R2D2
um icon rolling around yet where enemies
are attacking you from you'd never gauge
like the spawning is a little poor where
I never gauge what is the layout of this
map
um but then yeah touching on like the
death star mode I'm sorry the Trench Run
mode that
was actually pretty cool despite the
controls of these of these ships are
awful in my opinion like just awful I
like I am so frustrated with how they
handled it and that you can't do you
know actual 101 barrel rolls like you
you do really oh yeah it's really dumb
it's it's like a you know a pan so like
I can do a flip and the next thing I
know I'm upside down and I then it's
weird and then the control switch it's
like okay well you gotta straighten out
bud so like you're you're turning then
equates to like spinning back around but
it ends up making you crash however this
uh the Trench Run was really interesting
in that you the rebels basically have to
hit checkpoints in order to have the
ultimate goal of doing the Classic Blue
Skywalker um shooting Photon Torpedoes
down the
um exhaust
but what was neat is they and this is
where my worry was was that
okay let's get real the Trench Run it's
kind of a boring layout right it's just
a Trench Run what obstacles are there
other than any line other than like a
slight box it's like a boring Star Fox
64 right level but what they did is they
actually included
um very reminiscent of the second death
star and return a Jedi some actual
tunnels and one area in the tunnel is
straight up the exact representation of
uh return a dead eye uh Death Star 2
where the Millennium Falcon loses its
radar dish yeah what's going through so
I'm a tire Interceptor and I'm chasing
the Luke so every random every so often
you are picked to be as a rebel um Luke
Skywalker you have to basically be the
X-Wing and everyone on the maps shows
you so anyways you get these really
intense chases where you're going
through these tunnels just like a return
to Jedi
and it's like it actually goes in and
it's like eight Tie fighters swarming in
behind them and just crashing because
it's really tough to like get this chase
down and you know a lot of obstacles in
the way that was pretty neat
um I think they touching back what you
said Peter I think they
have been able to tap into that
spectacle in an appropriate manner like
seeing that exact representation it is
it looks really great of that one moment
in the second death star was really neat
and I felt like I was really doing you
know you want to be in that movie right
and I had that for a few seconds
but then the controls just go go whack
and like and I can't I can't have fun
that's the barrier is like the flying is
so poor that I just can't enjoy it yeah
it just feels like those moments are
stymied by just the kind of okay game
beneath it right when these things kind
of deserve something better like more
attention paid to the specific moment at
hand like to get that much more focus on
it Beyond just putting you there Beyond
just giving you a means interact with it
like really figure out okay what made
this special let's tailor everything to
make that feel special for someone
playing it versus cramming it into
another game it always felt very much
like an Ode to Star Wars rather than
like a good Star Wars game in itself
yeah so it's like it's like a toy box
for Star Wars fans almost and like
that's why I appreciate it and that's
why I think it's it's decent uh but I
just every time I get in I play match
and then I'm just bored I mean I say
like in the present tense but I haven't
played in eight months or so sure but I
was curious whether this DLC was
anything that like it was building on
the games Foundation or whether it was
just giving you more of what I thought
was a middling game to begin with
anyway cool so
that is Star Wars Battlefront the newest
DLC is the Death Star there's one coming
out early next year uh Rogue one scarif
do you know anything about that a little
bit yeah that sounds pretty intriguing
and perfectly lines up with Rogue one uh
so I'm not sure what planet scarif is
but I do know is that the heroes for
that are uh Ben middleson's character
the um uh director
Orson
chronic critics
or some chronic and then and then you
play uh generoso on the rebel side so
that could be really neat I mean you
know having the movie come out with that
uh be cool to see what they do there but
again hopefully it's good hopefully who
knows cool well you will be streaming
that right after the lobby today won't
you that is right awesome so that is
Star Wars battlefront's newest DLC the
Death Star DLC it's out now on PS4 Xbox
One and P PC if you have the season pass
if you do not have the season pass you
have to wait two weeks and then you can
start getting in that okay cool let us
know if you're gonna pick it up in the
comments below anyway I'm gonna shift
gears hard right now uh don't tell me
that was a Forza Horizon joke no I wish
though I would rearrange the running
order but uh no we're going to talk
about something hideo Kojima was talking
about yeah
uh Pete's boy uh no it was at Tokyo game
show he was talking uh to a few
different like I think it was just a
press conference panel yeah and he had
gone into some light details as he has
wanted to do about death stranding the
new Norman Reedus game that we've seen
that's such a weird the Norman Reedus
game oh death stranding yeah you were
just making fun of my phrasing but it
was a weird trailer that we first saw uh
around E3 at the Sony press conference
last year to say the least weird
the least weird to say that you missed a
comma in there I think sure oh yeah the
very least it was quickly yeah it was
weird uh yeah so I guess we wanted to go
into the light details that he did
mention but also kind of just conjecture
speculate and maybe what we want out of
it conjecture rate yes Specter uh so he
the weirdest thing he said was it would
be out before the 2020 Olympics in Tokyo
but then he clarified saying well
actually I'll take that further it'll be
out before the year that Akira was set
in which is 2019 right suggesting a 2018
release date just say it
what if it's almost ready and he meant
like December of this year I don't think
that's it I know sure but that'd be
that'd be crazy is this just Kojima
being Kojima and kind of making
myself I mean yeah he's not many other
people but is he actually like serious
about this or here's the thing with the
independent studio now without Konami
bringing down his neck do you think like
he even cares when it releases now I
think he cares I mean like to some
degree his reputation is on the line
here yeah so like what do you like what
do you think about the fact that
do you think that he has more creative
freedom like in this like probably he's
hiding up his own Studio but I don't
know I'm curious if that'll be a boon to
him in the long run or if that'll be
like too much Freedom whereas I think I
know what you're getting at right like
will he be someone hinge that like
you'll be indecipherable yeah uh no I
don't think that I mean there's going to
be some weird narrative stuff and he's
you know he always tries to inject this
sort of like misdirection or keeps
things really vague until the last
moment I think that's going to continue
I don't know it's going to be be like
more than it was with metal gear towards
the end and if you look at that series
as a whole he went to some pretty Great
Lengths to make some pretty ridiculous
stuff yeah
um
I think it's I think we're going to see
the same level of strangeness I don't
think I don't know that he can
I'm sure anyone can go farther than they
have before but I can't even imagine how
in this case there's also some hyperbole
about being like an online component
that's unlike anything you've played
before right it just sounds more like
hideo Kojima it does and like you know
it's like okay take it at face value
that would be great if he could somehow
reinvent what online you know
multiplayer slash Co-op gaming is but
that's such a hard thing to conceive
like how would you do that and the way
he describes it is like okay online
games people would fight it okay
traditional gaming people would fight an
NPC with weapons then people were
fighting each other then they were
fighting alongside one another and he's
like kind of tiptoeing around Co-op but
saying that people are going to be
connected to one another
somehow but not in the same way say an
umbilical cord judging by the trailer
yeah right I don't know like it's it's
weird so what does that mean like
in your world when you walk this
direction it pulls me back and so we're
constantly struggling to move a literal
connection yeah like that would be super
[__] weird like I don't know if
that's like a platformer where you can't
go too far or micro machines where if
you did Bush on that screen they blew up
did you ever play that no oh Micro
Machines 1964 is a Hidden Gem if you
will uh Kojima also said that it may
feature a female hero protagonist I
think with his words were you the one
saying maybe Norman Reyes isn't even the
lead character yeah I think that'd be
cool if he wasn't I mean like I don't
want Norman Reedus to be the thing that
is the focus of the game yeah it's the I
don't know I had this weird thing where
I identify actors as themselves not
really as the characters they play
unless they're really good actors so if
Norman reviews was the star of this I
would just be staring at Norman greatest
the whole time and I feel kind of
strange about that as we all would yeah
well his butt looks great let's be
honest he was completely naked except
for the baby attached to him that
trailer was weird uh do you guys have
any speculation as to what it might have
meant we talked about this back on the
lobby stage show but I don't know I saw
theories at those five things in the sky
were like Metal Gear Solid one two three
four five the baby is Metal Gear Solid
it's so attached to him he's crying it's
dead I think we should give anyone more
credit than being that obvious with
their references like if we're able to
guess that just by looking at it like
I'm pretty sure that's probably like
misdirection on his part yeah let's be
honest I guess so it can't be that
obvious so the but the strands are
connected to people
right yeah duh so there's multiple
strands I my suspicion is like were
those four or five figures
like being like
Gods creeping in are we connected to
them and then they're pulling us like
maybe each strand is like a sin or like
a problem you have it's all just puppets
he did focus a little bit on the idea of
death stranding but also live stranding
like what it means in real life right
like dolphins will sometimes Beach
themselves when they do so and they're
alive in the process that's live stream
and the opposite is death straining
how to read into that I can't even begin
to imagine
but death stranding is when like a dead
whale watches up on shore is that what
you're saying
that's almost what I'm saying okay but
I'm saying that there are two types of
stranding and he made a point to
differentiate between the two okay so
I'm trying to imagine how that feeds
into the actual like discussion of the
game maybe that's just in reference to
it wasn't Moby Dick Studios at first
before the reveal of five maybe he's
still just chasing the well and he's
never gonna catch it God yeah
put it by Kojima he could be like
literary like that he likes the action
movies but he's no adult you know what
he's doing I love that word yeah ever
since you said it to me all right any
other speculation about what's going on
with this game
is all like he doesn't have the best
history with
female characters I mean he has strong
female characters but I think maybe I'm
letting the whole quiet controversy
before the game release kind of I mean
taint my opinion quiet definitely like
put a like a real shitty veneer over his
history with women like it's not always
been spectacular but
um you look at some characters like
Merrell like you know she was pretty
strong she was pretty good
um
we'll see
it could be a female that might just be
his way of saying it could be male or
female you could have pick your gender I
mean didn't Norman Reedus have some
C-section scars on his body oh the hey
this this guy hi smart man hmm so maybe
he's just gonna use Norman Reedus as a
female lead as a surrogate okay I see
what you're thinking now
all right we're on the same page anyway
as for you leave your craziest uh
speculation in the comments below and uh
I kind of want to read those because I
have no idea what's going on with this
game we're still talking about the metal
gear Universe though right now
uh well now we are yeah well some
someone connected somewhat connected to
hideo kojimo uh Metal Gear survive
we uh we all watched the 15-minute
Gameplay trailer uh pretty universally
pan trailer
uh I think it was like last time I saw
was 14 000 dislikes and then as opposed
to a couple hundred likes uh and I think
like the immediate question is does the
metal gear name on it hurt it
uh more than the metal gear name I think
it's piggybacking off of the engine and
the the game that was built for metal
gear solid five I think that's the
problem uh Metal Gear Rising or
Vengeance you know that was a game that
had the middle of your name it's very
different but a lot of people liked it
uh I think the problem with survive is
like you know you take this game that
had these great interactions Metal Gear
Solid 5 I'm talking about here you know
with NPCs that were pretty smart and you
had a lot of these moments that were
really difficult to get over and you had
a lot of different ways of dealing with
it
now you're you're going up against slow
ass zombies who can't think for
themselves and you have someone else
helping you along the way like not just
an AI Co-op buddy this time a real like
do you really need two people to take
down a zombie
that's I mean there's like four and like
a huge landscape like it looks so boring
and uninteresting and add it add that to
the fact that they're piggybacking off
of a different game that I think is the
problem that people are it's a problem
I'm having it doesn't it does not look
like an interesting game Beyond a couple
of weapons they showed in the trailer
but a couple of weapons doesn't make a
whole lot of difference it looked like
the mechanics of Metal Gear Solid 5 or
ground zeros thrown into like you said
kind of this Bland zombie game it looked
like they were just trying to take a
base and then defend it like yeah like
world at work kind of uh you know Black
Ops zombie style I guess I mean what
we're seeing here looks nice the
animations are cool like when they when
action is happening the effects are
great this is freaking boring what are
we looking at right here yeah they
talked for a while it was in Japanese so
I had no idea what they were talking
about I'd have to ask Justin or
something but that was the yeah look at
this it's stealthy you have to sneak up
on a zombie that slowly no just use a
silence handgun and you're fine just so
they don't oh there's one biting my leg
good thing my friend is here to kill him
with a spear and full Kevlar body oh
that's those are the clubs that Kojima
was talking about the clubs oh man that
was part of the death straining thing
okay yeah and then there so like one
guy's a machete someone like the someone
else had a bow and arrow there's the
spear you see there I don't get why
these what situation these spec ops
soldiers found themselves in were these
are the weapons they're using oh
survival because mother base oh you want
to know how they got the weapons I don't
know they were transported to a
different dimension because this is the
this is the remains of mother base yeah
so the underground zero is a wormhole
opened up and transported all the
survivors to a different dimension how
dare I not know that
I don't know what is this do you think
this was just called like what else I
don't know what else you could call it
but if it wasn't Metal Gear survive I I
agree it would still look kind of boring
like a stealth game I guess it does it's
like a Sandbox stealth game almost like
a splinter cell with zombies and that
sounds like a a very very weird
combination it looks it and I have to
think that they're just I'm not seeing
any reason why these zombies are a
threat they're just standing there like
idiots they're minding their own
business and and I am so hell-bent on
not disturbing their business before I
kill them apparently they had uh they
show like environmental dangers like
you're pushing zombies onto these like
Road spikes they showed later on like
the zombies actually start charging the
base and see there's the full recovery
system still I wonder if the Sheep just
becomes currency oh it's attracting the
zombies I don't know I don't get I don't
get Metal Gear survive it seems like I
think it's universally disliked right
now and maybe universally it's too
hyperbolic it's okay at this stage it
appears to be a cheap cash in using one
of the most overused themes in gaming as
of late on top of a game that was kind
of really cool in its own right with an
iconic name attached to it yeah so this
is Standalone yeah this seems like a
poor it's gonna be 30 game yeah they
said somewhere in the vicinity of ground
zeros right which was 30. okay
um I don't know sometime next year I
wonder how long they've been working on
it but I I don't even get the over again
the trailer I saw was I don't know is
there an English version for the trailer
because I was watching the Japanese
version I don't get the overarching uh
like kind of resource management maybe
it's just like Metal Gear Solid where
you're extracting animals for hunting
and then just Gathering Intel and
whatnot which I don't know how what good
Intel would do in a zombie world but who
knows zombies like Brains it's so
bizarre like metal gear has all like
metal gear 5 had the uh the ghosts who
or who were the characters that were
kind of almost like zombies I thought
they're gonna play off that yeah I mean
they were those guys were fast and
strong those were serious threats like I
the moment you saw them it was like the
CH you didn't feel like you had to run
away because the game was like here's a
chase scene that was your only freaking
option was to get the hell away from
them here yeah what are we doing now
it's like a horde mode yeah capitalizing
on that as well it's not even a horror I
mean I guess technically but the odds
seem so stacked in your favor I haven't
seen the zombies pose a single threat
I got I don't get it yeah no it doesn't
look anything substantial and maybe the
price tag is kind of indicative of that
but it's funny to think also like not to
rag on middle gear solid five but like
like the distance already for for enemy
AI to see you is pretty generous right
like just just to add in
a dumber you mean you set up here just
to add in like a done reform of AI is
just like
where's the stealth I don't need it that
was just like a scene from The Walking
Dead I think that's actually transposed
from The Walking Dead but uh Rick is
just kind of stabbing people through a
chain link fence for about an episode
worth what is on their head
um the crystals yeah the crystals
right all right see I can't talk I'm at
the point where I that might actually be
a thing in this universe because there's
a guy with like full-on Hurt Locker
armor and then this zombie just
drunkenly tripped over the window I want
this game I want every game to be good
this yeah it doesn't look like it has a
chance
yeah okay all right we'll see what
happens with this I think that certainly
will probably enough mail gear survive
uh tell us what you think whether you're
interested in it what the hell is going
on in this game in the comments below
anyway going to move on to more zombies
sorry Resident Evil 7 biohazard uh so
there have been a few updates Twilight
uh is the new it's not the new demo but
it updated the beginning hour demo with
uh like there's a little more to see in
the mansion that we saw from the first
original Incarnation the demo and then
uh at Gamescom I played the lantern demo
and Rob you recently just what yesterday
went to Capcom to see a live stream demo
last week last week you guys see the
lantern demo I did with VR psvr right
yeah so I don't know what do you think
now that you've actually played it like
leaving aside the VR for now what do you
think of Resident Evil as someone who I
don't think is super into that Series
right sure yeah and this this demo was
very much different right uh you're
playing along the lines of a cat and
mouse and you're being chased by one of
those crazy Louisiana
cannibal nut jobs yep so you're That's
The Stereotype we all know and love
you're you're not taking any breathers
uh in this demo so I didn't get to have
any of those like open world or not open
world but like exploration elements of
the other demos but yeah you're being
chased the whole time and uh very much a
horror-esque Vibe I felt a lot of
similarities like you know isolation
alien isolation or even like Outlast
sure
um it was it was a little it was pretty
gripping I was into it don't say PT
though I will not it's nothing like it
it's a sore spot
um the prey yeah that's what the premise
is uh the lantern I guess you could say
is this woman of of that that family I
forgot the name of them uh but they're
Bakers Bakers that's right yeah so she
is just chasing you through this mansion
and you're going under floorboards
you're going between walls uh she's got
a lantern that uh is what you need in
order to pick her out from the dim-lit
uh uh mansion and
yeah it was it was pretty it's pretty
insane I was I was into it
um
and probably more so with the VR uh I
did play it again without it but the VR
element
really had me going I mean I'm one to
like fall for jump scares and here we go
and we are watching footage right now
Rob's jump scare coming up this might
not be it but I think we have some audio
later on but yeah there's one moment
where I
freaked out I mean uh yeah just to be in
a
immersed horror element where you're
just like being chased and you have to
go behind boxes and peek around that's
where the VR element like
shined sure and and more so than
anything else I feel like was being able
to you know you're kind of circumventing
a box and I'm looking between the cracks
of the box and and it helped it was even
like a plus to have that because I could
see here easier as I moved opposed to
like looking I could I could still look
you know you have that that freedom to
kind of uh peer around smaller areas of
sight
um and yeah of course it's there's
nothing like looking back and seeing
this woman I'm going to
that's the thing this uh so obviously
this is another flashback within the
game so this is not the main protagonist
to be playing this is like a VHS tape
you come across and the thing I found
with this when I played it a couple
months ago is that there weren't many
jump scares there's obviously the one
you're talking about and it does happen
when you turn around and she's right
there when you don't know it obviously
the lantern kind of uh gives her away
but that's the point it makes a little
more ominous but it was just like a slow
build of tension and Dread that really
drove this forward because at certain
point you saw like old school Resident
Evil puzzles but she's still this
constant threat kind of like the Nemesis
if you played uh Resident Evil 3. uh
actually uh in this demo I mean I'm not
gonna vouch for the game or anything
like that but the demo actually the one
puzzle that they showed it felt like
actually that was a breather not now I
think about it it kind of paused you you
find the puzzle as she's chasing you but
then you go back to where the puzzle is
applied and then the game kind of breaks
and it's like Oh I thought she was still
like free roaming while you're solving
it nah there was definitely because the
first time I did I took forever actually
uh she definitely wasn't around but yeah
those are kind of huh does she catch you
yeah a couple times oh a couple times
where I'm like opening trying to open a
locked door you know you're yeah it was
very much a path it was on Rails of
where I was supposed to be going but
um you know it was a little bit of a
trial and error so there's one door that
she came out of that I imagine to go
into uh didn't open and she turned
around on there you are yeah she's got
the key because that's like one of the
doors you can let her walk through so
you can get behind her kind of from what
I remember but as someone who has not
like like pee I know you've played the
series for a while and you're really
familiar with the series uh as someone
who's not particularly familiar with it
how does this like are you optimistic
about this game because uh obviously we
haven't played much more than that we
did see the trailer when they're
actually showing like Gunplay now and
actually a little more there's like this
like policeman zombie in a garage from
what I remember uh it was more of like a
Suburban setting that we saw there so
maybe that's part of the main game I
don't know if that's a flashback but as
someone who's not familiar with the
series does this kind of strike you as
something that you'll want to jump into
or is this something that's kind of I
mean without nostalgia in play I
wouldn't think of it I thought it was
yeah it was really fun I mean it makes
me want to play all these other demos
because I'm what I'm hoping this game is
is it's you know bits and pieces of what
you know they've been they've been
showing in different levels like it'd be
cool to you know change a corner and
then have this ride for a period of time
like I like that idea
um which is what it sounds like because
you find those those tapes right that
sort of put everything in that context
yeah structurally it sounds like a cool
storytelling mechanic it's like uh it's
like the book haunted by Chuck paletik
or like I mean there are any number of
frame stories where the main narrative
like contains these shorter stories in
between so I think they were saying some
of those VHS tapes you come across will
actually be related to the main
protagonist others will just be these
tangential things that kind of flesh out
the Bakers for instance or the house
you're in or the cabin you're in the
part of the marsh you're in but that's
what is really kind of pushing this game
home for me as of now uh it's gonna be
on January but right now I'm pretty
optimistic because I think residential
does need kind of a shot in the veins
especially following six is the last
number to entry and then you played
umbrella chore recently which they
removed the Resident Evil name from but
it was still Resident Evil game it's
like metal gear survive but exactly but
that was the segue I should have used
but that and that was not a good game
that was a god Fast Pace yeah 3v3
tactical shooter yeah so this is you
know they say they're trying to return
to the horror roots with puzzles the
puzzle they showed in this one is very
know it was pretty you'd have to be
pretty oblique not to solve it you know
it was pretty easy but I I don't know it
it yeah the demo felt like very much
segmented
um again yeah I was just like okay
puzzle time
um again I'm curious to know how these
all mesh because I think there was there
was something there there was something
cool about
um you know you're underneath the
floorboards and you find a note you know
there are bits of like story that I'm
definitely intrigued and I want to know
more about um I just wonder how how is
that going to be delivered because that
was the thing is I I wanted to explore
but you can't like you're being chased
so as long as there are successful ways
of transitioning between this area like
I mean I guess you could you could say
okay maybe I'll go back and play this
section again but I don't know like you
like what I'm trying to say is during
these moments of where you're being
chased like they sh I don't know how on
Earth they could like
put these moments of like okay now
you're now you're able to like look
around and read a note or something like
that I just found it was hard to explore
again like I just wonder how they're
going to mesh all this together I guess
yeah this was definitely more of a set
piece kind of a very scripted thing she
was traveling along these certain paths
and then when she heard something if you
stood up and ran too fast she would kind
of Chase you right so you know like
makes you crouch the whole time and then
right you were saying you were kind of
worried when you were under the
floorboard you're kind of hunching over
that was in the VR though right that was
very cool yeah you know just inherently
you just wanted to crouch because there
was a lot of moments of like
claustrophobic uh Vibes it was like oh
God this you know she's definitely above
me I when is she gonna like come out and
get me
um it was cool it was it was a fun
little roller coaster yeah yeah and then
like that's what I'm saying the big
mystery remains and I think we'll be
seeing more of in the coming months
before January because I think
I think Capcom is pretty aware that
people are worried they haven't seen
much gun play so I think that's they
were some people at Capcom were saying
that's why they included it in the
trailer people are worried about seeing
the thing that they've said the series
has too much of yeah okay yeah exactly
so they're saying like Okay now it's not
a Resident Evil game it's just going off
PT and that's a sore spot because
Resident Evil 7 was already in
development before PT was ever a thing
and then you know you have like people
like kawada saying no this isn't
something we're like piggybacking off of
but like Outlast 2 does the same kind of
horror as well so it's almost becoming
like this new I don't know this new
trend in horror this is first person
atmospheric narrative driven kind of as
opposed to the actual survival but the
new trailer in residual 7 that longer
one that showed more like survival
elements and they're talking about
there's going to be the green herbs that
you know like for healing there's gonna
be guns that you'll probably have to
conserve ammo I mean it really comes
down to inventory management right that
is the only aspect of survival that ever
existed in Resident Evil because you can
find enough stuff you just couldn't
carry it all with you yeah if they if
they can get that down if they can make
this sense of Discovery like think back
to the original Resident Evil right like
when you finally solved enough puzzles
and you unlocked a new part of the
Mansion or new section outside the
mansion that made all of the tedium of
going in circles in that one area worth
it because then you you really
appreciated this this new place and
again the fixed cameras gave you a very
strong sense of tension and atmosphere
if I can just do those three things I
think this game will be a good Resident
Evil game despite everything else that
it does like I think those are the
pillars that need to happen so do you
think it'll be structurally set up kind
of like a Metroid where you're
backtracking a lot and then to unlock
these new areas I don't even want to say
Metroid I mean no like the obviously the
more app comparison is like Resident
Evil one two three yeah yes I I do think
that if they are consciously trying to
you know yes do something new but do it
in the framework of a thing that people
have told them that they love and they
want more of it would behoove them to go
back and really break down what made
those games successful and why
and impart that knowledge into the new
formula as well it's going to be
interesting to see because you look at
the pattern it was like one two three
where that very the third person fixed
camera Inventory management then four
five six are much more third person
action driven you wonder if like seven
eight nine I I don't know if like how
long it's gonna go but you wonder if
they're gonna stick with this for a
while until the next thing comes along
or whether Capcom knows what it's doing
at this point or not there was a weird
period of transition I think for gaming
and especially International game
development
um where Japanese developers are trying
to make games to suit the West what they
thought westerners wanted because our
Market is bigger and growing where Japan
is shrinking and that's probably why we
got a lot of those action games I'm just
guessing here but it seems to be that
was sort of the right time and place for
them to do that sort of thing or so they
thought I feel like those days are done
like I feel like now they're almost
starting from scratch and looking to the
Past won't really inform us about where
they're going I think this game is
really setting the future for the series
like the tone for it and who knows
what's gonna happen yeah I hope it's
great like it's seen everything so far
seems really promising I haven't seen
anything apart from a few like technical
things related to VR like crouching I
was told there's not really a transition
you just kind of like hard cut
um that's really bad nauseating oh yeah
that's that's immediately a problem they
can fix that stuff cool but this game
seems like it'll be good outside of VR
anyway like that's just sort of the
icing on the cake
as long as it doesn't get rancid and
that's the challenge though because like
producer kawada was saying at Gamescom
that it's an obvious quote like you're
never gonna please 100 of the people but
in this case specifically you have those
people that have been around since
Resident Evil one two three I don't like
you know like the ones that people
usually came on for whatever we're ready
to walk away from the series there are
people that are more excited for
Resident Evil 2 remake because that's a
shirt that's not even a shirt thing
because that's an entirely like remake
game whereas like you know like remake
the GameCube game was already made by a
team that worked on the original but
then you have the camp that was
introduced with four which is an iconic
like third person action game how do you
kind of merge those two cans with seven
do you have to and how do you actually
bring them into the present and I know
that the team is very cognizant of the
fact that they're not going to do that
completely and I hope that they just
don't worry about that that much and
like definitely like convey the Resident
Evil Vibes that I'm looking for like you
said the inventory management like that
kind of getting a sense of space and
ownership over this Mansion or whatever
you're going to be in and then I like
the structure of it already
um I guess like the bigger picture of
things has yet to be seen hopefully
we'll see more before January but I
don't know like I'm optimistic about it
but I don't know you said like the VR
definitely exacerbated the tension of
everything
yeah and just you guys talk makes me
wonder like
what does this like cat and mouse type
of element like how does it actually
like transfer into the rest of the game
like how can you hit up your inventory
when you're constantly being chased well
that's that's just it right it could be
part of the whole cassette structure
where this is just literally a slice
which I kind of hope what an excellent
opportunity to experiment with all sorts
of different types of horror sure right
they could just run the gamut of you
know these great sort of horror
paradigms over the last few decades from
film within this game and like that end
gaming as well and uh so yeah I think
that's how that's probably going to
exist I mean they're literally cassette
tapes drawing in comparison to VHS the
movies that I think there's three uh the
found footage and that's like those
short stories contained on the tapes are
these like throw not throw away those
are these like kind of ancillary
segments that don't relate to the main
game maybe narratively but mechanically
they could be completely different which
would be awesome because then you get
this little like bite-sized kind of
breath of fresh air from like maybe the
overarching kind of system you've
figured out and that that's like what
intrigues me most and I hope they like
really go for that structure what if
some of them are like super
light-hearted tapes where you're just
like participating in like something
before the chaos and the horror maybe
like ants like the Bakers before they
became like the psychos that they showed
in the trailer interesting or maybe
there's like one where like they just
finished eating your legs and you are
crawling the whole way yeah
great that it was just a 12 second
segment just screaming
you still don't know what that finger
does in the beginning our demo the
Twilight time you could put it on that
hand the mannequin figure but like they
keep saying there's a purpose of it but
it's probably just that's what that's
exactly what I was thinking or that are
like kind of like plugging a hole in a
wall there's an ax as well uh they I
think they include the ax just to hint
that there's gonna be weapons but that's
the most subtle hint ever because this
is the first demo they ever released for
the game and I think it still is sitting
like at the highest most downloaded PS4
demo ever it was at like 3 million last
time we checked it hit 2 million back in
uh June uh but yeah I don't know it's
it's I'm very intrigued and excited
about the game as a Resident Evil fan
and as just someone who likes horror
games in general and on Outlast 2 being
pushed back to what I believe is going
to be after this now that's kind of
making the way for LS 2 a little easier
I'd say
anyway cool let us know what you think
about Resident Evil 7 biohazard in the
comments below it'll be out in January
24th I believe for PS4 Xbox One and PC
and now Rob unfortunately we have to bid
you farewell not a problem
and now we're gonna get Eric Tayon but
is he still alive Eric Tay is probably
gonna be very tired he's been streaming
Destiny's newest expansion rise of iron
since 2 A.M You Gotta Throw like rapid
fire questions at him like don't even
let him finish his answer just
interjects the new question right away
yeah yeah uh yeah he's supposed to be
coming in hopefully he might be
somewhere he might be dead when he like
left the stream room earlier he kind of
just he just had the most dejected look
on his face he looked like a zombie from
Metal Gear survive yeah and then he just
yeah I don't know he had this uh bottle
of weird looking liquid on his desk I'm
just kidding was it a drink or was it I
think it was a drink no just kidding
yeah so he'll he'll uh he'll rotate in
soon yeah what do you have going on this
weekend
this weekend huh uh I'm still plugging
away a Dragon Quest VII
um is a very long game and God it's like
probably 100 hours and I'm 60 some odd
hours in right now and uh it's a lot of
the same stuff kind of over and over
like the same like sort of fetch quests
and talking to townies it's Charming
it's a classic japanese RPG
but it's wearing me a little bit thin
um
other than that I might play a bunch of
Forza Horizon 3. yeah yeah okay we I
played a little bit of it earlier we're
going to talk about it later that game
is pretty fun yeah for sure bring Eric
Tayon
um on each time but yeah Forza Horizon 3
we uh here's Eric right now oh
yeah how's it going Eric hey what's up
how are you feeling I'm feeling
kind of all over the place to be honest
yeah yeah pretty much I don't know good
highs lows mids something we'll give you
a breather first because we're gonna
talk about Forza Horizon right now and
then we're gonna get into for honor and
Destiny rise of iron we'll let you just
sit here and kind of recover from I'll
drink my tea quietly are you not a
coffee drinker
oh man oh Mike loves that I love the
noise of slurping it really gets to me
anyway okay I really apologize to
everyone listening in the Stream you can
hate me it's okay we're talking Forza
Horizon three uh like an open world
racing game that Pete and I tried out a
little bit we did not like review it or
anything that'll be a Miguel Concepcion
for a freelancer for Game Spot yes uh
the Embargo is up the embargo's up yeah
the review is out it got a nine and a
lot of places are giving it a nine nine
five I've seen a lot of hundreds out
there yeah uh it's a pretty good game oh
you're serious yeah oh okay cool or I
know it's a good game I didn't know it
was getting like tens and whatnot well
you know yeah some sites love to give
tens some sites uh it is a game that is
beautiful uh it's very forgiving it's
sort of like arcade type driving like
you can pretty much pick up any car and
drive and be pretty successful you can
run into trees no problem you can hit
other cars no problem no problem I mean
you're you're free to do whatever you
want and it's really just sort of about
exploring uh the Australian Pacific
Coast uh so there's a great pretty good
variety like I only played for gosh 45
minutes uh which was a a great like I
really want to play the game
um and I saw like a lot of good stuff I
saw like I said beaches I went to the
forest I was on what looked like a golf
course and I shouldn't have been I was
in like a Lamborghini but I was doing
all this great fun stuff
um and it you know it reminded me of
some of the time I spent playing the
crew back in the day and that game it
sort of had a lot of the same stuff
it allowed you to drive explore a lot of
different locations too where this is
focused on one part of a continent the
crew is like all of America
there's something about Forza Horizon
that just immediately feels that much
more gratifying yeah
um I think it's that the driving is so
much better
um and the Landscapes are just crafted
in a much more interesting way
um yeah imagine that they actually like
focus on the driving in a driving game
and it feels good I ended up kind of
like doing the donuts while I'm driving
and then reversing and going in the same
direction yeah kind of down pat a little
bit
um I saw you when I came back from I
walked by your desk and you were just
going off this rock ramp into the to the
beach just jumped off a cliff into the
ocean clearly ignoring like the events
and objectives which is the cool part of
this game like that's why I wanted to
play it and I don't necessarily like
racing games or at least I don't
gravitate toward them and that's why I
want to I wanted something I could shut
off and maybe just play every once in a
while just for the joy of driving and
seeing this like what is a gorgeous
world of this uh like what is it
Southeastern Australian I'm actually not
sure which part I think it's mostly the
Pacific coast I don't know that's just
Southeast but yeah it um
yeah it just makes the the bare Act of
driving the focus and really fun um
there is sort of this overarching thing
where you're supposed to be
participating in car festivals or like a
music festival
um and you are
using these festivals as a means to like
build your brand and perform PR stunts
I guess they gotta find an excuse for a
narrative in this game it doesn't really
need one but there are some questionable
characters early on in like the intro
with like these uh these bro voices yeah
I know I you could pick from like a
set number of nicknames I forgot what my
character's name was like Natasha or
something I have no idea but I wasn't
particularly interested in the people I
was just more interested in the cars and
driving them yeah um but then yeah you
can so you can like create your own
events right and then that's where like
the multiplayer comes into play other
people can participate in them you can
make like challenges and upload them I
believe because again I haven't had I
haven't played that much unfortunately
but you run across these avatars that
are just like they take I think names
from your friends list or at least they
just take random people's names and make
them like your drive attires that you
can challenge yeah so just driving on
the road and this is the third year the
driver tire system has been in place and
I think it translates across games
maybe it's just a horizon thing I don't
know if it's a for it's a motorsport
proper thing as well but yeah like these
sort of you know they they're learned
behaviors from the way that other people
have driven and then yeah it's not like
you're driving with that person in this
mode like I was playing offline and I
still had driver tires on there no it
wasn't offline anyway I'm rambling now
and you're building up a garage the
whole time obviously sure it's kind of
fun did you have like an N7 car from
like Mass Effect through a DLC that came
along with it or something yeah that was
just there when I booted it up I mean
it's a but you know I'm driving past all
these cars where it's like that's nimr2
that's a Jaguar like
it makes me want to figure out how to
get those cars and drive them it is uh I
hate that idea like car passion I guess
that's a thing yeah we all have it
inside of us I think it's cars you just
need something to rip our chests open
and eat it out and yeah before it's
Horizon may do that Miguel our freelance
Reviewer is saying it's kind of like uh
well these are my words not his uh like
it's almost like that Call of Duty thing
I find myself playing Call of Duty
multiplayer just because of how
constantly I'm unlocking something or
how constantly the experience is
translating into tangible rewards
whether they're aesthetic or actually
affecting the mechanics yeah but he was
saying that's pretty constant here it's
like a flurry of just like oh you gained
this many followers you just unlock this
car you got this new you actually like
hire artists for the festival venue you
get points for driving like an [__]
yeah like near misses uh you know like
collisions damage Point like you just
are anything you do basically you're
gonna earn points which you know there's
something to be there's some question
there like okay is it actually making a
valuable experience when you add it on
top of the the great driving yeah why
not it is just sort of that extra layer
that makes it a little bit more enticing
did you get the chance to go much like
off-road on the beaches and like yeah
the actual in a Lamborghini I was gonna
say yeah like when you were supposed to
be off-road no buggy as opposed to a
beamer no I no that's what I'm looking
forward to do this weekend honestly
Miguel sold the game so well and just
even just playing it just a little bit
made me realize like yeah this is going
to be a great experience if I stick with
it
um we'll see yeah in terms of negatives
it's just Miguel was saying like minor
performance issues online which I guess
like yeah every game's gonna suffer that
clearly wasn't enough to like hinder his
experience and then he didn't like the
the brand narrative either I don't blame
him yeah kind of social media the
millennial generation I I can't stand
Millennials they're the worst
yeah I know you guys are too aren't you
I don't know borderline anyway Forza
Horizon 3 got a nigh on Game Spot so
check out that review by Miguel
Concepcion on our website
all right before we get to rise of iron
I know that's what you're dying to talk
about TED
but no we we can talk about something
that you have played pretty extensively
recently at least somewhat uh for Honor
finally had closed Alpha
um we've been hearing about this people
have been like searching for it a lot
and asking about it a lot but we finally
got to play it did it line up with your
expectation what did you expect it to be
and did it line up with your
expectations if feel like uh I was a
little surprised by uh I've been wanting
to play it like you said uh there's been
interest at least for me to want to play
it and it kind of shocked me at first it
was a little bit
um
I guess
more defensive in a way than I thought
it would be I I'm sure you can be
offensive but you know there's there's
definitely more mechanics going on than
I thought there would be you know
definitely with you know blocking left
blocking right blocking uh high and then
kind of like countering or like
countering a grab or countering a guard
break so there's a lot of like I don't
want to say it's rock paper scissors
necessarily but there's a lot of kind of
that kind of going on and I didn't
necessarily expect that and so I was
kind of explaining or describing it when
we were doing our live stream that it
was kind of frustrating at first because
all I want to do is kind of you know go
at them but it's a hate bringing up Dark
Souls but you know it's like
you kind of learn by playing the game
like oh I can't play this way I better
learn how to play the mechanics of the
game and kind of Master those I haven't
mastered those yet necessarily but I
could see how if you can make the right
reads
um and there's like a probably like a
pretty decent meta game going on like
that can be really fun it's just do you
want to put the time in to kind of learn
those like kind of subtle nuances learn
the move sets of the four classes for
each faction and kind of how they flow
how they fight so you know how like you
can kind of see where they're gonna
they're gonna attack from but it's not
always necessarily the case so it's like
timing your parries and all that stuff
so I think that's pretty cool to me it's
just I don't know if I'm gonna spend the
time to kind of get really good at it
unless like I play more in the office
and then people start whipping me in the
office then I'll kind of get triggered
yeah you know I totally agree with you I
think the people that take the time to
master uh defending and like you know
you see this thing pop up it's like this
Trifecta you can go black right left up
and then different character classes so
there's like three races and then each
one has two variants Fighters
um I was playing the uh like the samurai
ones a lot the heavy and the light and
after a while you start to see the
stance that the other players are in
that's what how you know whether if they
have like it raised over their head
you're like okay I'll Attack the right
or left if the Knight has it like kind
of to his left that was the attack
overhead I feel like that plays into it
but I felt like I definitely played
better when I was a little more patient
if possible uh I did try button matching
and you could tell the people that were
button mashing were also kind of just
ignoring how I think Ubisoft wants the
game to be played so I think over time
I'm worried it might lose players that
aren't really committed to like learning
it because it definitely has a very
strong learning curve I think I just
assume to be a third person action game
when you're in the middle of these uh
hordes of like uh minions and ads it's
it's like a Dynasty Warriors game you're
just plowing through them right but when
you're actually fighting the like the
heroes the other players that's when it
becomes like what we thought for Honor
would be
um and then like speaking of dominion
mode right here with this uh so there's
three capture points ABC A and C are
just normal capture points that you get
for points to like add up to I think a
thousand and then you get the chance to
kill the other Heroes and win but the B
is like this uh tiered Zone where you
help your uh your creeps push forward
into the enemy territory you take it and
then anytime you want to capture you
have to actually have your creeps
advance so that's where like almost
moba-esque yeah the other interesting
thing too is um in these 4v4 skirmishes
it's also how good are you kind of
communicating with your teammates
because you might 2V1 someone and it's
actually really tough at least when we
were playing or when I because I've only
played a couple hours but to to Really
Stave off two people at one time you can
you can kind of generally direct and or
uh Block in One Direction and that
sometimes will get them both but if they
kind of pinch you it's pretty hard to
kind of defend both points so you kind
of gotta you know maneuver around your
territories also maybe just run for help
sometimes you gotta watch your stamina
obviously so that plays another factor I
think it's like oh three on one I'm
screwed yeah no it's definitely about
placement as much as anything like more
than just the fighting because flanking
is a huge deal if you don't even see
someone coming behind you they just do
like an overhead like heavy attack and
you're done I don't know like the more I
played it the more impatient I got but
maybe that's just because I wasn't
giving it the chance to actually kind of
teach me because it does there was a
tutorial at the beginning there's a lot
of things that like I didn't really
completely grasp like there's a guard
break which of course course works if
they're guarding but if they're not
guarding it doesn't do anything yet it
kind of leaves you like there's not much
you could do against it if they use it
so there's a there's a counter to the
counter break how do you learn that it's
like you hit X oh really I think it's
like X or or a I forgot which uh I
forget which tutorial I'm watching PS4
Xbox One but there is a way if you can
see that they're gonna do the uh the
guard break because the little Shield
icon thing kind of pops up you can kind
of quickly hit that button and and stop
it but it's like a reflex thing it's
like uh you know sure and then there's
also like baiting people uh you know
kind of like going to your left hand so
they think you're gonna attack on the
left and then just switching to the
right really quick and attacking there
uh it's almost kind of like the threat
of what you're about to do can be more
dangerous than what you actually do
um obviously the threat isn't what's
gonna throw an ax into your head but you
get what I mean in the essence that it's
a mind game after a while uh like you
said I I don't like when you get
outnumbered but I think that's the point
they don't like it's that's like the
ganking I guess well there's that
Revenge mechanic too which is supposed
to kind of help you deal with two people
I I saw people employ it well and and
kind of kill two people at the same time
if you're not using it properly or don't
really understand how to use it properly
you could also just easily die so I I'm
actually interested I didn't get enough
time to watch other streamers but I want
to see what really good players look
like and what that kind of gameplay
looks like and then see if I'm
kind of motivated by that and like oh
wow okay there there's all these the
mechanics coming to life the way that
they see it and I could maybe play like
that too but when you're kind of going
in even though there are really good
tutorials just kind of hard to see some
of that stuff because of who you're
fighting and whatnot yeah definitely and
it feels like it's almost odd that I
don't want to not disparaging Ubisoft I
like a lot of their games but it seems
like you know like when you think you
saw I think Assassin's Creed and you
think of like Tom Clancy games and you
think of things that are gonna be safe
somewhat but then you have like Rainbow
Six C's that came out which is just like
very tactical like high skill ceiling
multiplayer and I have four honor that's
coming out that's kind of the same thing
it's like player versus player focused
uh very high like you know easy to learn
difficult to master kind of thing and uh
I don't know that it's not like a trend
coming out of the entire publisher but
it's still uh now that we know more what
it's like it's intrigued me but I again
I just don't know that I can really
Mount that skill ceiling and kind of
like Get over the first few hurdles to
actually really enjoy the game and like
like it for what it is we've only
yeah I mean sorry to cut you off there
but I'm also kind of curious about what
that campaign looks like we saw kind of
a brief little snippet at E3 is it kind
of one of those that's shorter but gives
you like a kind of like a story kind of
thing for the for the factions or is it
kind of more in depth we haven't we
don't know yet obviously so I'm
interested in that maybe the campaign
kind of Spurs you on to play multiplayer
you know yeah definitely I mean it
released in February I believe yes I
think so because it got pushed back it
was originally earlier but I guess every
game was pushed back now but you know
what you could play Bushido Blade right
now is that a comparison you've been
making yeah Bushido Blade uh one and two
PlayStation fighting games where it was
like one-on-one sword duels and there
was no health bar if someone's sword
hits your arm you lost your arm you just
had that one other arm to fight with
someone cut your leg you died and it was
this great dueling thing because it just
captured the reality of like what these
impacts could do and it would just
restart a fight like that so you could
like have these sort of like rapid like
duels like that really do like teach you
like you're gonna learn what you're
doing or you're gonna die uh captures a
lot of what I think this is going for
but without all the Clutter of modern
gaming demands that things must have if
it comes from Ubisoft it has to be this
big like Bushido Blade is a pure dueling
game and that's out you can play that
right now yeah because you could just do
one on one and four honor you could do
2v2 then the minion modes would the one
with the creeps and everything I think
that's one I had the most fun with only
because I wasn't completely married to
the mechanics of the game even though I
think the mechanics do feel good I just
don't think I gave it the chance like to
like I gave myself a chance to really
like learn and respect it I guess I
don't know but yeah I don't know so now
I'm intrigued by the game for sure uh
that releases in February of 2017 on PS4
Xbox One PC and uh yeah
check it out in the future we'll have
more coverage on Gamespot I'm sure there
will be a closed beta so yeah we'll see
how those change for sure all right it's
time to talk about
the game that you've been playing for 10
hours or no sorry yeah 10 hours you
played 10 hours today of Destiny rise of
Iron's newest expansion uh I don't know
but we need to be clear this is the
second time he's played this stuff
because you've already played it yeah an
event like two weeks ago yeah so I went
to Bungie uh was lucky enough to be sent
there to kind of it's like a review
event almost because you were out of
town so we we wanted to get some
coverage out of it features or video uh
but that felt rushed I felt like I I got
through the story which
um fortunately isn't too long uh I
actually like the story I think it was a
cool kind of concept uh it just didn't
last that long it's probably about a 90
minute maybe hour uh sorry 90 minute
maybe two hour type ordeal and then a
lot of the what the rise of iron is
comes after that so you know you explore
the play glands you do
um R Gardens Forge which is like a new
kind of
uh Court of Works prison of Elders
hybrid that's kind of faster that's like
nine players public event yeah in the
patrol area and and then the raid
obviously Friday we have no idea I
didn't get to touch the raid at all so
at that event it was a little bit rushed
they're trying to do different things
capture different things just didn't
have enough time kind of going through
it more today
um say it's okay uh I think like I said
the story is pretty pretty good but
short I think the rest of the stuff is
kind of the same old same old a little
bit just in a different world uh I I do
like some of the lore that's coming out
of some of these quests I like some of
the quality of life stuff they've added
so it's like they have a book that you
can you know go through if you finish it
you know you're getting tangible rewards
which helps kind of a casual player
who's playing you know maybe by
themselves or with one friend who can
actually do that maybe not be able to do
the raid they still have something to do
right I think those are all good things
um really for me now at this point it's
just about the raids because the strikes
are kind of just remastered versions of
old ones that with twists and there's
like one new strike that's okay I mean
you've played some of it too now and
yeah and you're um looking into doing a
review in progress I believe you know
what are what are some of your thoughts
yeah it's it strikes me more as DLC and
actual expansion like uh taken King was
it's not revamping the foundation of the
game it's not actually like changing
what I think about Destiny I do like
that they're kind of going for this
almost like high fantasy Game of Thrones
s kind of thing which they've said like
I remember them saying like that the way
they're telling the story and trying to
like
this is how they like justify like how
shallow the story was before they're
saying we just want to introduce details
which we were planning on going into
depth with later which like you know
like you learn all these characters in
Game of Thrones or whatever and then you
learn about them like in an entire
episode later on in the next season but
I it hasn't it was like 90 minute
campaign I believe I might have gone
through it faster and it's just going
into Lord Saladin who usually shows up
for the iron Banner events uh it's
detailing kind of uh what's called Siva
this uh like Nano robot plague and it's
kind of got like hints of like an
allegory for like a nuke it was this
weapon that it was this thing that
people could have used to like create
anything it was like renewable energy
but then of course like the Fallen
um and like old Fallen sects started
using it for ill and uh now you're kind
of fighting it back again I won't go
into spoilers what happens but it just
kind of feels like the story rushes by
and I never really got the impact of
what was going on which was always like
a thing with Destiny I never had there
was contacts for what I was doing and I
knew why I was doing it but I never felt
like I was enjoying like the story
pushing me along it just felt like I was
doing it for the sake of getting through
the missions and getting that reward at
the end
yeah I mean
like there are there aren't that many
missions I mean one in particular is
really good but it'd be going to spoiler
territories I kind of wish they'd use
that to kind of mold the rest of the
stuff but you know it's hard uh when I
went up there they did say that you know
they started production of Rise of iron
like end of January you know so it
hasn't been that long and they've kind
of
kind of got a lot of stuff out there
even if you want to say it's a reskin
and stuff like that I haven't gone
through enough of the quest stuff yet
too because there's four exotic weapon
quests I've done two today they're
pretty extensive if you want to get your
year three Galler horn back again which
is a thing
it's took me probably as long as the
story like that's how long it felt like
it took me so you know there are people
that are uh fixated on some of those
past experiences you know of gallerhorn
and and the fun they had with that and
they're gonna do that right that's
that's a good another hour and a half
and then like the cost Cava stuff excuse
me the first gun you ever get in the
game they have an exotic version of that
fan almost like fan service because
everyone's always been asking for the
cavastoff and the the mission for that's
pretty like not bad it's pretty good and
there's a nice little
nugget of lore at the end that's kind of
cool but
um sometimes those moments feel few and
far between like you can you can feel it
sometimes like oh this is really cool
and then sometimes you're just like oh
yeah okay I'm just kind of like plodding
along and doing things you did kind of
touch on it but I think I've played at
this point about five to six hours since
this morning and I think of that time
I've spent maybe 45 minutes in new areas
um you know excluding the social area
but it's just you the for one of the
first missions you do you're retreading
the ground that you started the game in
back in what 2013 2014 like the very
beginning of the game and story area the
what the little outdoor area yeah before
you cross the wall and uh into the wall
uh but yeah it's not like the strikes
the new strike the archon priest was
kind of a little novel like this ogre is
chasing you around you can't hurt him
he's pretty much just this nuisance that
you're kind of trying to avoid while you
shoot the priest who's also obviously
very capable of defending himself uh the
other streak is uh our strike is suffix
perfected suffix Prime who we fought I
don't even know how many times by this
point again it seems like a Twist it's
retreading a lot of what we've already
seen I do like the aesthetic of the new
stuff though that like that fantasy kind
of climbing the mountain to fell
Winter's Peak the new social area
um I haven't done a lot of archons Forge
I've done one and again you said those
are like when you offer things up to the
to like Siva or to the gods or whatever
yeah it's pretty quick Pace fast action
that's kind of what they want it's like
a mini horde mode a little bit more
frantic than that at times because you
know there's explosive Shanks and
whatnot and as the tiers get higher it
does get harder of course that's because
you know level difference and stuff like
that if you're not of levels obviously
going to be harder I was doing heroic
strikes
um I think they're like 350 at like 347
and some people were even lower than
that and people were just getting gibbed
and dying really fast it's kind of
frustrating actually
um but yeah to be honest like for me
the story and everything's great I like
it but ultimately I think for me as a
min max hardcore player The Raid is
really what's going to tell me how much
I like about rise of iron it's kind of
been the case for you know a lot of the
previous DLC expansions and
um we'll have to see that doesn't come
out till Friday yeah hopefully we get to
check it out hopefully you get to check
it out because it is a big part of
like these DLCs and expansions I feel
like it's like probably a good third of
it you know there's like I'll probably a
whole separate team just making the raid
I think it's also like Bungie's best
chance to show off their level design
and their mission design and everything
because those are the most nuanced like
how do we kill his boss and then you
beat him and it's like such a big deal
and then you get to the next mini boss
and obviously the final boss is pretty
like usually a very intense battle and
everything
um again yeah I after what I've played
we're gonna have a review and progress
up soon
um we're gonna wait until obviously the
raid goes up because that's the make or
break thing for me on Friday but until
then I'm sure we'll all be working on
getting our light up so we have a decent
raid team going in hopefully and I mean
like on a side note because this is
something that normally affects reviews
and Peter you know uh best of all is uh
we both luckily escaped cue hell as I
would like to call it because when I was
streaming there was I think Xbox one was
struggling I think they almost like had
PS4 servers up first or something a
priority I don't I'm this is just
hearsay this or sorry this is my side
info to me it's not it's not inside info
it's just observations um and it seemed
like more people were struggling on
trying to hop on Xbox One
um as well as PS4 and I I can't remember
to this date that they even had cues and
it just reminds me of a World of
Warcraft thing where it could totally
like alter your experience because I was
pretty much just apologizing to people
in the Stream I'm like I'm really sorry
I don't have any privileges or anything
to stream I just got lucky I spammed got
in that's kind of how servers like for
these kind of games work once you're in
you just don't leave because you're
screwed if you leave and people are like
I'm 30 000 in queue which is kind of
insane if you think about it like that's
a lot of people that are trying to play
the game like yeah I got lucky I didn't
have any problems getting in I got
booted off world a few times yeah
are disconnected from Destiny server so
luckily I've not had any performance
issue well I've had a few but nothing
nothing
played a fair amount of PVP but couple
hours today between Supremacy and uh
what was the other mode uh Supremacy is
the new ones the pharmacy is a new one
that's like kill confirmed from Call of
Duty to pick up people's tags needed to
actually get the kill to count or get to
extra point and everything I've been
playing Rumble and everything and then I
the one alluring aspect at least as far
as progression goes is the the book of
iron a record book of iron or something
and that's where you know you're
actually doing these rise of iron quests
you're kind of unlocking these tiers
that are giving you the cool looking
armor that you know like we've been
seeing on the cover for how long now
yeah it's also one of those sweet like
oh yeah these are not achievements or
chivos but you know there's things that
you see and you're like oh okay I'm nine
out of 90 done I'm gonna finish that
boom work on the next you just I think
it's just uh innate sense at least for
me when I see something like oh I gotta
finish that or if I can that's called
OCD Eric
okay
he's got his chores to do oh God I got
chores obsessive chore disorder yeah
that's pretty true so anyway that is
Destiny's rise of iron expansion uh
presumably the last one for the last
major one for destiny that they've kind
of been hinting at for a while yeah
they're gonna fill it out with events
and stuff like that and I think the big
thing that everyone wants that has kind
of been talked about but hasn't been
like really confirmed is everyone just
wants to go back and do the raids sure
have them bring it up or something
something that would allow us to go back
and do the raids because everyone loves
Balta glass it was like the first one
everyone it's probably most people's
number one raid uh and I could see them
doing that because you got a big gap
between now and next September you can't
just fill those with you know uh
Halloween and uh winter events so yeah
wouldn't be shocked yeah anyway so
there's rise of iron and uh in the
meantime I'll be getting my light level
up kind of working on the review and
progress which will go up soon and then
if like we said the raid will be up
Friday
following that we'll put up our full
review and that unfortunately is all the
time we have today oh man thank goodness
hey I know what you'll be doing for a
while hopefully you get a break sleeping
right yeah that's that's what we would
all suggest but I know that's not what
you're gonna do I'm gonna try my leg was
I we're at the lunch table earlier I
think my leg was involuntarily just
shaking I was like Justin you see that
my legs kind of shaking yeah you know
it's not I'm like I feel the muscles
man all right we will let you get back
piano you said you're gonna play some
fours this weekend and everything yeah
more Dragon Quest seven
yeah long game you have to play through
for that yeah it's just getting good
it's I think it's we'll say yeah it
unlocks stuff super late so I'm still
unlocking stuff
all right well everybody thanks so much
for joining us thanks to John Luke
sidekick in the back Eric Tay is here at
the table but he's usually back there as
well Mary Kish is back from Tokyo but
she is not in the office today Richard
Lee on the camera as always until next
time have a good week
Papa